Bộ công tyng cho biết bộ đang chỉ đạo tập đàn định lực Việt Nam EVN
chính khai thị điểm giá định hai thành phần từ tháng mời.
Á dụ với nhóm khách hàng sẽ sất tư thủ biển quân trên hai trong những kí loa dở trên tháng,
khoảng 18 kíng cơ dở, trước khi tổng kết để quyết định áp dụ chính thức từ năm sau.
Giá hai thành phần gồm biển định năng theo sản lượng tư thủ và tình công sất theo mức công sất đang ký hàng tháng,
khách hàng phải trả ghi phía công sất ngày cả khi không sự dụng,
có chế này nhằm phản ánh đúng chỉ vì đầu tư.
Bận hành hệ thống, khuyến khi tối yêu hành vi sử dụng định giá đạn đầu,
bộ công tư khảo sát, tu tập sữ liệu,
nhưng cứ phương ánh tính phù ở trong nhóm khách hàng thì điểm.
EVN khẳng định hạt tưởng đó đến, chính gián đáp ứng yêu cầu trên hai.
Bự át dụng sẽ theo lộ chính, sau sau công tác trên thông để tạo đồng thuận xa hội.